Pablo Rodriguez ministre du Patrimoine
canadien bonsoir
bonsoir merci de nous savoir il fallait
il fallait vous entendre puisque cette
décision de Google fait en sorte que ça
se corse dans le rapport de force entre
canadien et ces géants du web David
contre Goliath votre réaction à chaud à
tout ça et vous surpris
es parce que se poursuivent avec Google
alors surpris pour pour trois raisons la
première c'est que la loi est pas en
vigueur puisque il faut les règles pour
ça donc Google est un sujet absolument
rien pour l'instant deuxièmement parce
que justement les discussions sont en
cours et je vous dirais que sont plutôt
positives et troisièmement ils savent
très bien que les prochaines étapes donc
les étapes qui touchent la
réglementation sont les étapes où on
clarifie les choses exactement qu'on
avait fait sur le projet de la
précédente et 11 ouais quand même mais
tout ça c'est inscrit dans un dans un
rapport de force ou très clairement on
tente d'exercer de la pression sur le
gouvernement canadien qu'est-ce qui se
passe on est on se sert du Canada comme
un bander ça un laboratoire un cobaye
dans ce que vous dites vous savez le
Canada
ose aller de l'avant le Canada hausse
tenir tête à des géants du Web et il
l'accepte pas donc il y a quelque part
oui il essaie de envoyer un message non
seulement qu'un gars mais à la France à
l'Angleterre à l'Allemagne aux
États-Unis mais nous on va continuer à
installer de vous vous savez les salles
de nouvelles à travers le pays
disparaissent ils vont continuer à
disparaître donc le satu quo il est
absolument impossible on a besoin d'une
presse qui soit libre forte indépendante
non partisanes et les revenus sont
actuellement à deux compagnies Google
Facebook et ça on peut pas on peut pas
continuer vite comme ça donc vous
maintenez le cap malgré tout malgré
cette pression supplémentaire qui
s'ajoute à celle de méta jusqu'où
irez-vous pour défendre les intérêts que
vous jugez légitime dans tout ça
mais on voit toujours cette guerre de
boule pensez-y là on peut pas accepter
qu'une entreprise multinationale dans
une entreprise américaine
aussi grosse qu'elle soit avec autant
d'avocats qu'elle est aussi riche que
soit on peut pas accepter que cette
entreprise vienne chez nous dire au
gouvernement du Canada je sais que vous
avez un paquet d'élus là mais vous allez
faire ce que moi je veux ça on peut pas
on est un pays souverain alors on peut
pas avoir mis une entreprise dans ces
cas-là ou ailleurs lire du tout
gouvernement et au peuple canadien quoi
faire mais toi c'était entre guillemets
essayer avec l'Australie énormément de
grogne dans ce cas-là aussi tout ça
c'est résolu en quelque sorte avec des
ententes parlez-nous des des solutions
mitoyennes de ce qui pourrait être fait
négocier avec ces géants du web pour
éviter que les Canadiens subissent
finalement cet obstacle à une
information libre équilibrée variée
je peux vous dire qu'il y a encore des
bonnes discussions avec google et je
peux pas négocier sur la place publique
on l'a pas fait dans l'accord avec les
Etats-Unis le Mexique c'est justement
qui nous a permis d'avoir autant de
succès mais je peux vous dire ceci c'est
que il charge plus de clarté et c'est
clarté là on leur offre à travers la
réglementation donc avec les prochaines
étapes qui servent pour ça que j'espoir
que qu'on puisse qu'on puisse à terme
s'entendre c'est pour ça que je suis un
peu surpris parce que
comment s'entendre pardonnez-moi
permettez-moi de vous interrompre
comment s'entendre avec un partenaire de
négociation qui va de ce genre de
décision là qui quand même va à
l'encontre de ce que vous défendez des
objectifs que vous voulez atteindre
d'ici donc six mois le moment de la
promulgation de l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi
je pense que comme toute compagnie qui
négocie établir ce rapport de force ils
nous disent voici nous on attend faire
cela ce qu'il faut à terme je sais pas
mais en parallèle il y a des déductions
qui se poursuivent et qui sont en France
ouvertes ils sont pas toujours facile
les discussions et c'est normal mais
rappelez-vous une chose c'est
compagnies-là ne veulent pas être
réglementées vous êtes réglementés vous
devez suivre la loi vous et moi essayez
de briser la loi demain matin ce qui va
vous arriver les compagnies canadiennes
doivent suivre la loi s'ils ne suivent
pas ils vont payer le prix alors
pourquoi vous allez avoir des gens du
web qui vont débarquer chez nous faire
ce qu'ils veulent sans aucun impact
c'est c'est pas acceptant
ultimement les conséquences elles
pourraient être l'autre pour ses
compagnies
mais pour lesquelles Google metal les
autres qui refusent d'obtempérer qui
vont de mesures comme celle-là
ben je veux dire il y a des conséquences
d'affaires si eux prennent la décision
de se retirer ben il y a des
conséquences de revenus et des
conséquences réputationnelles et après
d'autres choses mais si ça retire de
chez nous puis la France s'en va dans la
même direction les États-Unis est-ce
qu'ils vont se retirer de partout c'est
une question qui c'est une question qui
doivent se poser aussi et que doit se
poser les législateurs ici au Canada
est-ce qu'il y a lieu justement
d'accentuer la position commune des élus
à Ottawa face dans ce dossier on sait
que les conservateurs sont un peu bande
à part
le Bloc québécois nous appuie totalement
le NPD nous appuie on a plus du
gouvernement du Québec plusieurs autres
collègues vous savez je suis
actuellement à Toronto et une rencontre
des ministres de la Culture donc c'est
position de tenir debout pour les
Canadiens
qui arrivent face à ces menaces qui se
multiplient est-ce qu'on doit en faire
plus
moi je suis très claire c'est pas je
suis pas essayé de je voudrais pas faire
ce que l'année ça comme je pense pas que
ce soit nécessaire qu'il le fasse est-ce
qu'elle a dit non plus ce que je
souhaite moi c'est qu'on poursuivre les
discussions ils sont en cours et comme
je disais mon chef de cabinet leur
parler ce matin et moi j'ai parlé la
semaine dernière ça fait un an qu'on se
parle sur une base régulière et il doit
je pense qu'il y a moyen de trouver des
solutions ce niveau de clarté dont ils
ont besoin ça vient dans les règles donc
peut-être un peu de patience et à
soyons-nous à discutons là très bien
alors patience et beaucoup de ont
portera une grande attention évidemment
à l'évolution de tous les détails dans
ce dossier merci beaucoup Pablo
Rodriguez on vous dit à une prochaine
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]